je suis pas à la hauteur
[Musique]
politique ce matin c'est vous Jean
Lassalle bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous candidat à la présidentielle
pour votre mouvement résistons et en
étant ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale avec toujours à mes
côtés Julien Lecuyer de la Voix du Nord
très bon article très bonjour
je pensais pas moi qui l'ai écrit mais
je le prends pour moi merci
parler évidemment dans la salle de votre
programme de votre campagne mais d'abord
un mot sur l'Ukraine quand vous voyez ce
qui se passe en Ukraine ce qu'on a
découvert dans la région de KEF de Kiev
avec ses cordes de sévril massacrés par
l'armée russe est-ce que si vous êtes
élu président de la République vous
dialoguerez vous continuerez à dialoguer
avec Vladimir Poutine d'abord c'est la
guerre
et il y a pas de guerre gentil
c'est pour ça qu'il faut tout prix
éviter ça s'amuse là il est référence
surtout lorsqu'elle est civile et elle
est pratiquement civile dans cet ordre
là c'est tout juste je connais ensemble
nous sommes battus
alors oui bien sûr il faut reprendre le
dialogue avec Poutine qu'est-ce que vous
voulez tout le monde le dit ou ceux qui
ne le disent pas
d'imaginent sa poutine meurt bon dans
l'état actuel des choses ça pourrait
râcher peut-être bien des choses mais
bon il n'a pas l'air de vouloir mourir
non plus je lui souhaite pas non plus
mais enfin encore qu'on sait jamais mais
s'il ne meurt pas qu'est-ce que vous
faites il est là vous avez vu tous ceux
qui se sont attaqués à la Russie elle
est tellement immense moi je l'avais
découverte à mes 20 ans et trois ou
quatre un auto-stop j'avais déjà peur de
la bombe à l'époque j'allais à
l'autostop j'avais quelques copines qui
me faisaient passer le mur de Berlin
d'un côté avec un costume soviétique de
l'autre côté avec un costume que vous
avez dansé au bolche
vous continuez à dialoguer avec Vladimir
Poutine il faut continuer à dialoguer
est-ce qu'il y a les deux jambes
c'est-à-dire à la fois discuter
continuer à discuter avec lui mais aussi
accroître les sanctions ou pas c'est à
dire les sanctions si elles servaient
dans quelque chose oui le seul problème
et Poutine avait très très bien anticipé
ça doit faire lui est pas venu comme ça
il y a quand même
véritable moi j'ai le pouce crime de
l'OTAN depuis 20 ans il a donné des
signes il supporte pas marqué non si moi
j'avais fait la même chose avec la
Belgique la Hollande fait son vouloir
minimiser qui que ce soit bon
c'est-à-dire si la Belgique avait enfin
je comprends en fait c'est à dire que si
on avait vu les Soviétiques ou les
Russes maintenant
vous voyez mettre des populations etc
au Luxembourg ce qui est plus voilà donc
maintenant
qu'est-ce que je vous dise est-ce que
vous président par exemple vous diriez
un petit peu comme comme vous avez dit
avec en janvier 2017 je vous aviez vous
aviez rencontré Bachar el-Assad vous
disiez je suis dans l'incapacité de dire
qu'il est ce qu'il fait c'est bien ce
qu'il fait c'est bien ou mal je suis pas
tribal je ne suis pas là est-ce que vous
pouvez dire la même chose vis-à-vis de
valadimir Poutine c'est pas tout à fait
de la même nature mais en partie oui en
partie oui
parce que ils sont tous les deux
au coeur d'un enjeu considérable et tous
les deux dans une situation
à peu près indéfendable monsieur lassa
est-ce que vous pouvez dire ma question
était dans le sens où vous disiez à
propos de Bachard je ne sais pas dire si
ce qu'il fait est bien ou mal
est-ce que vous pouvez dire si Vladimir
Poutine fait quelque chose de mal ou de
bien à l'heure actuelle alors je vous
suggère
[Musique]
elle a saute était confronté comme elle
avait été quelques temps avant au
problème de la Libye un problème de
l'Irak c'est-à-dire des pays qui ont été
ravagés alors six mois parce que on
avait mis par terre leur chef d'État qui
n'étaient pas des Pygmalion de bonté etc
mais ils étaient tous les enfants de
Nasser
de
laïcité arabe et
à cette situation là et moi ce que j'ai
vu de Bachar el-Assad c'est qu'avec une
armée de conception et malgré l'appui
des Russes et des Turcs qui n'étaient
pas le meilleur cadeau comme Michel lui
faire il avait fait daesh tout seul et
l'autre il s'appelle les autres
sympathiques et sauver l'intégrité de
son pays alors après moi quand j'ai vu
sortir de l'EP que je connaissais si
bien 30 ans avant j'ai vu les soldats se
précis j'ai vu les habitants de
possibilités sur des soldats j'ai jamais
vu ça avec la gloire civile en Espagne
j'ai jamais vu ça avec l'arrière de
rouge ensuite Poutine la poutine c'est
pas pareil parce que Poutine
histoire en fait de la Russie
d'être ça l'URSS ce grand rêve gémonique
que dans ma cristallisé dans sa tête il
va être en place l'un des l'intégrité
d'un territoire l'autre c'est c'est un
empire donc à partir de là est-ce que je
trouve qu'il aime sommes mieux là que
l'autre je ne reconnais pas assez mais
je les connaîtrai si je suis président
on va parler du reste de l'actualité
vous avez vu que le parquet national
financier a ouvert une enquête la
semaine dernière sur McKinsey pour
blanchiment aggravé de fraude fiscale
c'est suite au rapport du Sénat qui
révélait que makingsen ne payait pas
d'impôts en France qu'est-ce que vous
pensez l'ouverture de cette enquête
c'est une bonne chose c'est le minimum
qui pourrait être fait pour tenter
d'éteindre le feu à 60 heures de scrutin
très important c'est bien la moindre
chose ce qui m'étonne au cabinet de
conseil si vous êtes élu président de la
République
écoutez si la France la France
du peuple sera de la Déclaration des
Droits de l'Homme et du Citoyen la
France qui a
procédé au cours de ces deux ou trois
derniers siècles avec nos amis du
Royaume-Uni à la plupart des plus
grandes inventions du monde n'est pas
capable de trouver un sens l'ingénierie
et l'administration suffisante mais
c'est un véritable déni de ce que nous
sommes c'est en cela peut-être que ce
scandale est le pire c'est
l'affaiblissement de l'État c'est le
rejet de nous-mêmes c'est que nous nous
cachons à la figure nous-mêmes donc nous
crachats vous ferez appel au génie
français plutôt qu'au cabinet de
conseils
étrangers ou français d'ailleurs il y a
des cabinets de conseils Capgemini est
un combat cabinet de conseil français
oui
qui a fait d'ailleurs de très bonnes
choses mais
Thomas il a 70 olympiques mais pas que
mais
il faut les deux il faut les deux moi je
pense que toute bonne politique et
faites de grosses il faut à la fois
c'est pour ça que je dois reconstruire
honnête c'est bon et après
à l'état avec le chef de l'État avec le
gouvernement de voir où sont les
meilleures compétences d'accord un mot
sur la Corse puisque c'est un dossier
que vous aurez à gérer si vous êtes élu
président de la République est-ce que si
vous êtes élu vous poursuivrez les
discussions avec les élus de l'île sur
la question de l'autonomie oui bien sûr
mais je l'ai poursuivré d'une manière
moins crispée je les poursuivrai un
évitant les mots qui fâchent et Nutella
et maintenant qu'il fasse pour vous
et qu'ils ne veulent pas voir le
président Simeoni ni l'assemblée et
quand vous êtes Corse mais vous imaginez
vous même que vous soyez de l'île de
France ou partout mais alors à plus
forte raison de Corse essayez de faire
ça au Pays Basque vous allez voir on va
faire une autre programme oui alors
votre slogan invoque la France
authentique
mais par cette France authentique moi
j'ai du mal à déterminer ce que ce que
vous entendez qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que vous appelez authentique
c'est-à-dire justement vous avez raison
de poser la question parce que il faut
que dans toute
dans toute
recherche en tout nom il est une part de
curiosité je l'ai passionné mais je veux
rester purement laïque parce que je suis
très républicain de mystère
et à cela c'est complètement gagné parce
que tout le monde m'a posé la question
tant pis
c'est très simple madame c'est
l'authenticité qu'est-ce que c'est
authentique bien
cache il est totalement et la France est
authentique et aujourd'hui elle se
désespère de ne plus retrouver notre
décidé tous des calculs et tout est
millimétré si je dis ça si je fais pas
ça si je non la vie heureusement et plus
simple heureusement qu'on s'abandonne à
l'amour quand on est jeune ou un plus
tard heureusement qu'on s'abandonne à la
vie quand on est un peu peinard et on
finit même par se la donner à la misère
hélas quand il y a plus rien à faire
mais il y a toujours l'espoir
l'authenticité c'est une capacité de
résilience du commun doublé de l'espoir
le folle espoir c'est l'espérance folle
tu connais ça
mais je ne reprendrai pas
authentique en tout cas vous êtes
décrivez cette cette France puisque vous
promettez à la fois le maintien de l'âge
de la retraite alors je vais pas refaire
tout votre programme et promettez
l'ouverture de 20000 groupes
parce que ça va me permettre de de vous
poser une question importante le
recrutement sur 50 cent mille soignants
100000 le RSA jeune revalorisation des
salaires des enseignants baisse de TVA
recrutement de 6000 policiers gendarmes
tout cela sans jamais nous dire combien
ça coûte monsieur LaSalle
combien ça coûte mais je la fais
strictement rien c'est embêtant parce
que vous croyez que il y a un seul de
mes hanches colère oui qui savent ce que
coûte leur mesure
le niveau
de recherche et le niveau intellectuel
de Public Sénat pour vous faire cette
injure personne vous pensez que Macron
je connais à une validé
pour proposer alors je peux je peux
entendre la critique mais pour proposer
des mesures il faut j'imagine que vous
êtes projeté en disant j'ai un budget
comme n'importe quel ménage je dois
dépenser ça pour mesures et ce que j'ai
suffisamment d'argent non le problème je
suppose même pas comme ça c'est qu'il y
a plus de budget c'est que nous sommes
en état de vente depuis euh
comment faire en fait
d'abord je regrette
ensuite
je relance immédiatement de la recherche
fondamentale appliquée premier objectif
c'est trouver la nouvelle source
d'énergie renouvelable à mon avis c'est
le soleil j'ai vu le solaire le soleil
pas vraiment nouveau le solaire non mec
qui est-ce qui a avancé de ne pas depuis
fort romain puis je cite sauvage ce
matin parce que vous connaissez par
coeur mais ça c'est c'est très très
puissant ça
hésité en 62 d'ailleurs c'est pas lui
qui a pris la décision ne se laisse oui
mais je vous dis je dois faire rentrer
dans l'argent parce que l'argent il y
avait il nous a été tout enlevé il est
chez Niel chez tous les copains que je
cite souvent il est là ils sont 5 ou 6 à
tenir la fin et il y en a une
cinquantaine il était une longueur
encore une fois vous prenez l'argent
chez eux chez les Xavier Niels
d'après moi pour me le donner non par
contre si je crée de nouveau un état
d'esprit si je dis non la France c'est
pas foutu non la France a connu 1870 et
qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait derrière le
plus grand projet d'instruction publique
qui a appris cette record absolu à toute
une jeunesse à apprendre je vais recréer
du travail et je vais remettre le
travail à la mode
président a réussi dans les deux ans qui
viennent comment vous remettez le
travail à la mode
d'une manière totalement différente de
ce qu'on fait les 35 heures ça a été une
horreur absolue mais 35 heures non parce
que il y en a qui veulent être 35 heures
mais pourquoi voulez-vous que ce soit
toujours l'un ou l'autre je dis question
vous travaillez comme vous l'entendez
mon problème à moi et celui de mon
gouvernement c'est de recréer les
conditions qui me permettent de vous
proposer suffisamment de travail mais
qu'est-ce que c'est cette histoire de
partager le travail est-ce que vous le
partagez vous qui faites 70 heures de
travail par semaine
il veut faire 70 heures et bien il se
l'étape les 70 heures il y en a un qui
en veut 25
équilibre mais aujourd'hui quel
équilibre entre quoi et qui tellement
tout est flou donc pour répondre très
concrètement il y a des
extraordinaire dans ce pays d'abord un
intelligence
inutilisée chaque fois qu'il y a un bébé
qui dit c'est réservoir d'intelligence
deuxièmement ce pays peut tout produire
ce pays peut tout transformer il est à
la croisée des mers des Belges elles
sont pas mal des avions de tous les
passages tempérés partout et nous avons
la chance d'avoir des bouts de France
que nous allons perdre si nous
continuons comme ça qui tutoie les plus
grands empires du monde nous avons la
possibilité d'utiliser l'énergie de la
mer chose sur quoi nous n'avons rien
fait à part juste comme bout de France
il faut une politique adaptée à chacun
de ces merveilleux bouts de France je
crois que il faut travailler d'avoir sur
leur histoire singulière
de Mayotte
vit un enfer avec tous les migrants qui
de partout là pour le coup Zemmour je
sais pas qu'est-ce qu'il ferait ma fille
vaut mieux pas qu'il y aille parce qu'il
y a déjà assez de panique comme ça c'est
pas la peine qu'il y aille en fait c'est
pour vous dire que il faut s'adapter
mais moi je je serai de trouver par
exemple l'idée de l'homme de la mer de
l'homme des mères c'est à dire ces
hommes qui sont quand même singulier
sont pas tout à fait comme nous comme
l'homme des vallées
ressemblait étrangement un homme
insulaire c'est pas la même chose et il
faut trouver voyez des grandes idées qui
transcendent les hommes et qui fasse que
ils aient envie de s'associer
magnifique comme vous parlez beaucoup
d'organisation de l'État est-ce que si
vous êtes élu vous reviendrez sur la loi
notre est-ce que vous mettrez fin à ces
grandes régions
il y a beaucoup trop de petits personnes
pas petits au sens le petit parce que
moi j'aime pas qu'on dit ce petit
candidat mais c'est des catégories c'est
beaucoup donc il y a une énergie à cours
de froide alors
vous revenez à la fois sur la loi ou
autre et puis sur la loi Matam madame
m'a posé à la fois sur les régions et
vous vous avez subreptistement
c'était pas l'objet
oui je reviendrai progressivement mais
avec les acteurs
parce que j'ai deux ou trois dimensions
nouvelles que nous devons s'inventer
ensemble il y a notamment celle de cette
représentation des provinces qui
n'existent pas et qui fait souffrir les
Français ça a été un grand oubli de la
République on oublie volontaire et avec
elle il y avait les langues et la France
maintenant je suis très républicain et
la France mon Dieu existe mais elle peut
s'enrichir des différences des couleurs
des productions de ce caléidoscope
magnifique que quand c'est de la France
complet
nous avons la chance de les avoir c'est
notre patrimoine quand vous avez la
chance en patrimoine est-ce que vous
connaissez beaucoup de gens qui ont de
batterie aujourd'hui et qui le laisse
tomber surtout ceux qui en ont beaucoup
une question très prosaïque mais vous
président la première préoccupation des
Français étant de pouvoir d'achat
qu'est-ce que vous mettez en place
directement à votre arrivée à l'Elysée
sur ce sujet
il aura pas le choix il faut couper
court à la Révolution c'est-à-dire que
je baisse la TVA 5 5 pour tous ceux qui
est carburant et je laisse je fais en
sorte que les prix de ce qui est qui
permet de manger
voire de se loger si c'est possible ça
de nouveau accessible sur le logement ça
veut dire quoi sur le logement vous
parlez de du premier poste de défense
des Français c'est le logement en effet
mais vous faites quoi à mon avis dans un
premier temps je pense qu'il faut
apporter un peu d'ingénierie d'aide à ce
que les jeunes aurent de s'y
remarquables c'est de vivre ensemble à
plusieurs dans des logements ça c'est
pour la colocation vous voulez dire mais
c'est génial de manière pour se déplacer
nous on avait l'auto-stop
ils ont le vivre ensemble
vous vous connaissez le principe on
arrive au bout de cette campagne il vous
reste plus que 3 jours pour faire
campagne avant le premier tour comment
vous l'avez vécu cette campagne bon je
l'ai vécu comme tel que je l'ai dit
c'est-à-dire
que elle s'améliore un peu d'ailleurs
depuis que je l'ai dit vous avez vu tout
le monde a aussi le temps a commencé par
vous le fait pas le temps mais le niveau
jusque là c'était Gémeaux voilà tous les
faits divers etc mais rien sur le fond
rien sur l'énergie rien sur le logement
ou pratiquement pas dans la presse
régionale
[Musique]
de sortir ton itinéraire
le plus j'ai voulu montrer qu'on devait
tous sortir de cette dictature et au
final vous sortez euh vous sortez
heureux de cette campagne vous y êtes
quasiment à la fin ben écoutez j'en sors
serein c'est évident parce que j'ai le
sentiment que j'ai un peu tout contribué
même si je suis parti très tard vous
voyez vous m'auriez lancé tous ensemble
République c'est là tout le monde LCP le
monde etc qui ne me lâchera d'ailleurs
jamais tant qu'il y aura Niel et bien
j'aurais eu beaucoup plus de chance là
j'ai un déficit considérable mais tout
est possible parce que c'est quand même
le lecteur
essayez de faire un pas de clairs
moi je constate que lorsque en 12
candidats se présentent je suis député
depuis des années j'ai fait de la
politique toute ma vie et que je suis
même pas sur la tranche du fil de ceux
qui ont essayé le fil là quand le fil a
coupé le beurre
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on vous empêche de
faire campagne est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
vous empêche de développer votre profil
en vous détruit c'est à dire que Staline
était obligé d'envoyer ses opposants à
Sibérie les Américains à want tanamo on
a avec la dictature molle qui s'est
installée de ces grandes sociétés de ce
c'est pas de société même c'est beaucoup
plus complexe que ça et difficile mais
cette dictature bonne voilà la capacité
et vous la première et si jamais si vous
ne plaisez pas à vous laisser vous
dessécher toute seule et vous
disparaissez toutes seules et il y a
même pas votre belle-sœur si ça ne veut
la dernière question Julien oui alors
c'est des amis
si vous échouez ma présidentielle je
suis bien obligé de d'observer cette
cette hypothèse serez-vous de nouveau
candidats au législatif parce que bon en
effet vous l'avez rappelé vous êtes
député depuis 20 ans est-ce que vous
n'avez pas peur au final de faire partie
du système que vous dénoncez
du travail à faire pour que j'arrive au
système que je dénonce pour le reste je
suis là et je vais vous dire
merci Jean Lassalle merci beaucoup
lorsque vous avez des journalistes au
point et intelligent qui est libéré de
la dictature molle
je suis libéré merci beaucoup
à NES de l'Ukraine se prépare
merci Julien merci Jean Lassalle
[Musique]